los que quieran su nuevo iPhone 14 van a
tener que esperar más de lo previsto la
multinacional Apple ha confirmado lo que
ya se tenía que la política zerocóbita
castigado su producción que de China
saldrán menos envíos y que la temporada
inminente de navidades quedará afectada
el origen del problema Está en la
fábrica de Chencho con más de 200.000
trabajadores y donde sale la mayoría de
los iphones la detección de los primeros
casos provocó que muchos trabajadores
huyeran para evitar un confinamiento
inminente desde entonces la compañía ha
estado achicando agua a derivado la
producción a otras plantas y ofrecido
importantes subidas salariales a los que
se quedarán pero no ha conseguido más
que mitigar el problema
chenchowi es solo una de las varias
ciudades chinas sometidas a
restricciones en el país se registraron
más de 5.600 casos el domingo lo que es
la mayor cifra de los últimos seis meses
Es decir desde aquel brote que obligó a
cerrar Shanghai durante tres meses china
sigue aferrada a la política de Cero
covid y la volvió a defender este sábado
a pesar de que en las redes se
especulaba que iba a hacerlo contrario
Así que muchos se vieron abonados a la
frustración esa política cerocovich
sumada a la caída de la demanda global
explica que haya bajado el comercio
internacional chino en octubre tanto
importaciones como exportaciones algo
que no se daba en los dos últimos años